[Music]  [Music]  Jordan I spent a lot of time on the road  or backstage at a venue and we sing to  each other and so it was something that  came up in the creating of the  characters within the story it's like so  this is a song I'm not really sure what  they're doing it oh they're doing it the  patter between them was truthful and  funny already you figure out a way to  get the keys we don't sit over here  good luck with the cat and I think  that's what we get with duckie and bunny  it was so important that they read each  other's minds they needed to be able to  finish each other's sentences he needed  to be able to annoy each other and be  best friends they would do anything for  the other one but at the same time they  get on each other's nerves you would too  if you were connected to another being  for your entire existence  [Music]